virtually every multiplayer game to ever
exist has matters some come and go and
have little effect on the community but
others are so ridiculous that they leave
you wondering what the hell the
developers were even thinking
holy [__] that is unnecessary I hope
they take that out for actual
competitive play some matters are so
bizarre that you're left questioning why
you even bothered to play the game that
day but before we get into that I just
want to remind you that we have merch
head to shop.thescore.com and check out
our new black and ivory touch grass
hoodies they are super comfy and now
here are some of the stupidest matters
that ever existed
kicking off our list we have one of the
dumbest matters to ever grace Street
Fighter and it comes from Four's arcade
edition when the update dropped in
December 2010 it came with young
returning to the franchise he was busted
on release with excellent movement great
damage and insane Frame data basically
it wasn't surprising when the game's
producer admitted that Capcom
intentionally made him op but the
stupidest part of his move set was his
dive kick the main reason his movement
was good was the dive kick the un's dive
kick travels across the screen extremely
quickly
and he could threaten it even from a
neutral jump
and because of that the opponent
couldn't just DP whenever they saw you
on leave the ground in case he didn't
dive kick
on most knockdowns young could easily
use his dive kick 3 position things like
escaping the corner were trivial even if
the opponent quick Rose Jan quickly
became a problem with many top players
like Daigo switching off their longtime
Mains and onto the new character oh yes
hit confirm innocent agents
and hopefully he hits the whole thing
this time we'll see
but again what's the mix up afterward
that's the question wow I didn't know
that was a hard knock down I've never
seen that all right here we go John has
got to be close to dizzy at this point
oh I like the back that's there Twin
Back Dash is so strong
and tygo takes it from John Choi
after a strong first round from John
everything else was all Daigo even after
Capcom finally nerfed him Yun was still
annoying to play against it didn't help
that dive kicks were dominating multiple
games at once which led to Young's
dominance partially inspiring an entire
parody game which featured a character
named kick a direct reference to young
young was so powerful that he basically
defined Street Fighter 4 arcade edition
and to this day fans are still tilted by
just how stupid he was
sniper has always been a strong hero in
Dota 2. in fact most players would tell
you that he's brain dead and requires
basically zero skill but when valve
decided to buff his shrapnel ability in
patch 6.83 he became completely busted
well in trouble about to fall
assassination it'll get the kill
everybody has BuyBacks except for the
Army night no racks has been gone
they're holding four versus five
but the real reason everyone remembers
this meta is because of sniper's voice
lines
snipers shrapnel ability was so down
busted that his obnoxious Voice still
haunts Dota 2 players to this day
Rainbow Six Siege a game that has seen
some pretty awful matters we've already
covered broken operators like finker and
Lyon on our Channel but there was one
brief matter that believe it or not may
have been even dumber back in March 2018
patch
3.1.0 finally brought some Buffs to
Blitz in an effort to raise his pick
rate Ubisoft made him a two-speed
operator most people probably thought
this was a reasonable change but the
developers had forgotten one thing about
Blitz since shields in Rainbow Six
already have a natural speed reduction
of 0.5 the buff likely should have made
him run at 1.5 speed but once players
started playing him on the game's test
server they realized this wasn't the
case those of you that don't have access
to the TTS Blitz is a monster right now
I would go as far as to say as he's the
most overpowered op they've ever
released in the game certainly the most
annoying up Blitz was fast as [__] and
it didn't help that Lion's ability
forced you to sit still while all Blitz
ran you down luckily Ubisoft recognized
their mistake and made Blitz act as
intended when the patch went live but
even after the bug fix his movement
speed with his shield equipped still
felt pretty fast Ubisoft even released
yet another statement to prove that the
average round length had only been
reduced by nine seconds over time his
pick rate has gone down but everyone
still remembers rushing sights with
blitz and ending rounds in seconds
oh my God
valorant has had no shortage of
ridiculous matters whether it's weapons
or agents Riot has a real knack for
releasing overpowered [__] and in
the early days of the game there was a
lot of nonsense throughout 2020 one
weapon in particular was just plain
stupid Texas left
holy [__] that is unnecessary I hope
they take that out for actual
competitive play in custom games
shotguns are often used for their Close
Quarters capabilities but the Bucky
could pretty much be used as a sniper
rifle and because the price was merely
900 credits Eco rounds just didn't feel
like Eco rounds you could buy a rifle
for 2 900 credits only to get right
click from a ridiculous range with a
Bucky
oh
the rain is really low rain is so low
I can't believe that
one enemy remaining
last time then please Ace this tens
please this is free YouTube content
the fun at all but thankfully in patch
2.06 Riot finally answered everyone's
prayers nerfing basically everything
about the Bucky nowadays the Bucky
actually feels like a shotgun you can
still buy it on eco rounds but it's not
nearly as deadly as it used to be
goats may be the matter that drove
people away from OverWatch but it's not
nearly the stupidest no that honor goes
to the double shield matter I love
double shield don't you guys love double
shield let's go I love playing Sigma I
love playing Reinhardt I love playing
Harissa as the 2019 OverWatch League
playoffs were approaching teams figured
out that running two Shield tanks was
broken and that became even more
apparent when Sigma was released this
forced players to either break the
shields or play Heroes that avoided them
entirely it wasn't fun to watch and it
sure as hell wasn't fun to play
Shields yes dude yes Shields Shields
Shields Shields Shields put around
another Shield another barrier another
barrier to replace this barrier that
just died just put down another goddamn
Shield yeah I love Shields Shields are
so much fun I love shooting Shields
what is happening dude
17 billion Shields this matter had a few
comp variations over his lifespan but
its worst offender was the bunker cop
with both Shields set up Bastion would
hunker down in turret form and melt
enemies from afar you do actually have
to stop the cart at a certain point in
time check your Hunters you can't just
stand here and shoot at it while it
moves they do know that but instead they
put an ice wall on it the Bastion
composition is so unforgiving you get
caught once you get slowed you're out
there I mean the highest DPS of the game
sorry you're just dead it's not gonna
happen you're not getting out you're not
gonna turn the fight around you start to
lose momentum against Sebastian and
things just get out of hand very quickly
both teams were basically just playing
to keep their Bastion alive arguably
making OverWatch the most unfun it's
ever been even today that was easily one
of the most ridiculous comps that
OverWatch has ever seen
back in 2018 League of Legends saw
arguably its most boring matter ever
gold funneling one of the team's carries
typically the mid laner would funnel all
their gold and XP into one jungle hyper
carry on the team such as Master Yi and
Kaiser speaking of down we do see that
black she'll be on cooldown for a little
bit used on Baker okay they get the sun
you're on to bigger and he nearly Goes
Down super low and down will go over the
light is looking to do it now tall is
gonna go down and it doesn't look like
they can do it faker's gonna get tossed
up on the right side too and that's
gonna be the end of that team fight as
Griffin able to clean up you want to see
some numbers here's some numbers that's
a number nearly 10 000 in one fight the
entirety of the enemy team and more of
course most mid laners swap to Tanki
supports like Tariq and bought support
gold generating items to help support
their junglers and keep them alive even
without much Farm double F gave a great
explanation of the ridiculous Strat to
Blitz Esports when it first became
viable basically the entire point of
gold funneling is to interact with the
Enemy team as little as possible and to
just put all of your resources into a
champion that can hard carry and I feel
like it's not fun to watch it's not fun
to play and it's especially not fun to
play against goal funneling in solo
queue wasn't as much of a big deal for
an average player because if you ask a
random person on your team to funnel
their gold into or build they'll likely
tell you to [__] off but it made pro
play an absolute snooze Fest Riot
finally fixed things after a few months
changing Hunter's machete so that lane
minions would Grant 10 less gold until a
jungler finished enchanting it this
marked the end of the gold funneling
matter and honestly good riddance it was
boring as hell just change the Gold
Funeral links throughout so I don't need
to play Rome again
all right that was our list of the
absolute worst meters in Esports but do
you have any that really wound you up
specifically let us know in the comments
thanks for watching and I'll see you all
in the next one
I really hate the lane swap matter in
League the team with a stronger bot Lane
they might go all right well [__] this
we're gonna match you so they they would
send their Duo up top but guess what the
other Duo would then just recall and go
but within about a week of this
happening people knew that there's no
point fighting it it was one of those
things that actually if you're a pro
player or a coach or whatever there was
a lot of like chess games going on but
from a viewer point of view you know
watching a game where you might not have
a kill in the first 10 15 minutes not
hype I would say